There was another special election yesterday,
this one in Ohio's 12 district and as a
to go the race still officially too close
to call, although the Republican candidate
in the official result is ahead by about 1700
votes, but this is still massive, massive
news and the Republicans are trying to downplay
it, but the big news wouldn't be that the
Republican one, if the Republican does end
up winning by the current count of like I
said, 1700 votes.
The news is the Republican didn't win easily
because this is a hugely, massively red district.
80 seven percent white district that hasn't
had a democratic representative since 1980
3:35 years ago before I was born and certainly
before pat was born and in total has had only
one democratic representative dating all the
way back to 1939, 79 years.
You have to go back for the second democratic
representative and Ohio Twelfth district.
And more impressively, uh, only one of the
last 41 terms were held by a democrat.
Of course, when you consider the the number
of terms that the Republicans have served
compared to the Democrats, you have to go
back to 1939, not just for the second Democrat
to control this district to be the representative
for this district, but just for the second
term during which the seat was filled by a
Democrat, as I mentioned, the voting results
as of a very, very recently, just hours ago,
1700 votes separating republican troy Balderson
from Democrat, danny o'connor, and as of right
now, even if the Republican Ekes out this
victory, whether it's 1700 votes or 2100 or
1300 pending a recount, absentee ballots that
still have to be counted as well as provisional
ballots.
This is a red flag for Republicans in November.
Does this mean Republicans need to assume
Democrats have it in the bag?
No.
Does this mean democratic voters can stay
home because Democrats are just going to kill
it in November?
Absolutely and totally not.
Does this mean that if something big happens
like trump invading Iran, republicans can't
have massive gains because of those bogus
talking points.
Like you can't switch horses midstream when
it comes to military engagements.
No, all of that stuff can happen, but what
it does mean is that this is a big change
of direction in a massively red district.
Republicans had to spend millions in this
race to eke out what is maybe a 1700 vote
victory, victory you had here of race that
Donald trump won a this district easily.
Mitt Romney won this district easily and it
was so tight that trump personally went to
Ohio to campaign for the Republican over the
last few days, and still we have the possibility
that the Democrats could win, although not
hugely likely based on the number of votes.
This is a very bad news for Republicans.
Cautiously potentially good news for Democrats,
but I don't want a single Democrat in any
district thinking it's okay to stay home because
of these results,
right?
Because past performance isn't necessarily
indicative of future results.
Sure.
So maybe the best attitude we can have when
it comes to this is just to treat all races
as if they're 50 slash 50.
We do have a shot at winning this, but you
have to go out and vote.
You can't rest on your laurels.
According to the cook political report, there
are right now of the 435 house seats, all
of which of course are up for reelection.
There are 68 seats that are currently held
by Republicans that are more in favor of Democrats
than Ohio's twelfth district.
Democrats need 23 seats in the house, a net
gain of 23 to take control of the house and
68 Republican seats right now have better
numbers for the Democratic candidate.
Then the Ohio Twelfth Congressional district
that is maybe part of if we had to come up
with like is there anything good about trump
being in the White House?
There's very little good about it, right?
If there's anything that we can say might
be a positive side effect of trump being in
the White House, it's that it's created a
little bit of space for some progressive ideas
to be floated around and it turns out that
a lot of those ideas are really popular and
more popular with Republicans than maybe we
were pretending for a very long time.
There's new polling which points out that
a federal jobs guarantee has more than 50
percent support nationally.
That means that there are Republicans who
support it.
A community job creation programs, more than
50 percent of the country supports it.
Government producing generic pharmaceutical
drugs more than half the country supports
it.
A public Internet utility, basic healthcare
services for all, every single one of those
ideas has higher than 50 percent support,
sometimes way higher than 50 percent support,
and one advantage I would say the one advantage
to trump in the White House has been that
some Democrats, especially some of the more
progressive candidates, have decided to just
say the things that therefore, when before
they might have been more posturing and coy
and calculating politically.
Not that I say, not that that's a good thing,
but it's good that they're now actually saying
these are things that I'm for and what we
are finding is that among moderate Republican,
some of these ideas are actually relatively
popular, so it's a good sign for Democrats
in the fall.
It's not a good for Republicans, but nothing
is guaranteed and I think pat's idea of consider
every seat 50 slash 50.
If you think about it as it's 80 percent chance
that the Republican wins, you might stay home.
that the Democrat wins, you also might stay
home.
Think of every racist 50 slash 50.
Nothing is guaranteed.
Get out there and in the context of looking
at data to figure out what might be happening
in the midterms, there's one other big piece
of news from last night which is that for
the first time ever, voters have blocked one
of those horrible right to work laws that
was passed by Republicans.
It's massive and that's what I want to talk
about next.